so let's get started
traditional relationships are they dead
are they still alive when we say
traditional
let I want to find out because the
people have their different views of
what the traditional relationship is
um
can I ask what people's views of a
traditional relationship is to them
jump in anybody jump in the woman the
nurturer and the man the protector and
provider mm-hmm
are those dead yeah
undeniably so I say really yeah I think
um
I think it's difficult for men to want
to provide because of
city girls
um and things alike and that's
understandable and I think women are we
have rights and we are independent and
we can do what men can do these days so
there's just like it's like a
what's the opposite of retracting
you think we can do what men can do
well I mean I can pay my own way and I
can put I've been protecting myself in
all my relationships so in that sense
yeah well I'm just thinking if someone
breaks into your apartment what do you
call a man
well no I don't you're gonna go down the
side of the bed and and shake and
prepare myself because I'm single I
don't have a man because I had to get
rid of him because he wasn't protecting
me
but
well he wasn't protecting you what do
you mean he wasn't making sure that I'm
safe in all areas mentally
financially oh okay so he didn't make
enough we didn't make anything I was
supporting him and and happily oh god oh
you're dating bomb
um yeah I mean I think it's and it's not
wrong I'm not saying that you know that
it's it's wrong that men are like that
because
I can understand it times have changed
we can't deny that it's not men don't go
out and work in Coal Mines anymore and
do you know what I mean so
it's understandable but it's very
difficult for both men and women I feel
what do you think
traditional relationships are they dead
no I don't think they're dead like
everyone has their own take on
traditional relationships I mean what
was you saying about like the woman like
basically staying at home and then not
staying at home but being the nurturer
being like the emotional and what not
one I feel like yes because men they
don't really show emotion like that
yeah they don't want to because they're
scared getting finessed and whatnot it's
true and like nowadays it's just so hard
to know what's true
it's hard to know it's true like
someone can say they're in love with you
but how do you know they're really in
love with you
you don't think Love's a choice
it's like their actions
you don't think so in some relationships
yes but I think in you know in certain
relationships you don't have a choice
it's like a force you feel forced well I
think that's like long term how it used
to be you know what I mean like because
like you think in a 30 40 year marriage
you're gonna really feel love every day
of course like some years you're
probably not going to like them that
much true
yeah I agree um so I was listening you
know what it was I want to listen to
what you guys had to say before I said
um sorry okay so yeah so
no I believe traditional relationships
do exist because I still believe they
still happen but if you talk about the
niche
what tradition traditional relationships
and were initially know that that is
dead so you're not really gonna well
tons of you getting a woman that's a
virgin right it's it's unlikely
um depending on the age depends on
that's not true no no I'm just saying
I'm just saying the chances in the
dating world in the dating world what
percent of women over the age okay the
average age of first marriage in the UK
what what age do you think it is over
30.
what percent of 31 year olds are virgins
as women
probably five right it's not that high
yeah
plus 31. you're telling me this girl's
waited half her life cat I don't believe
a single girl that tells me she's over
26 I'll give you and is still a virgin I
don't believe you women are losing their
virginity are like 14 now like yeah yeah
it's because of social media all these
cardi B songs you know
so yeah so sorry yeah so yeah so um so
traditional in a sense of the world yeah
that fundamental what tradition was
based on oh yeah that's gone but there's
there's something else that we could
consider as traditional goals so what's
the one we say if you've got her body
counts over below five or something that
makes her somewhat so the new
traditional woman is a woman with the
body count below five no I'm just saying
you can't change you can't change the
definitions
100 but what I mean in a sense of um
so
like existing and or as part of a
tradition long established that's the
definition of traditional yeah so I
don't think so in order for you to have
a traditional relation traditional man
or your traditional woman so the thing
where a lot of women want to have the
cake and eat it they want to live single
lives while they've got a man and still
want to access some of the benefits of
of being a tradition so for you um Emily
for what you said in regards to the guy
that you you was with he just wasn't a
good guy he was a bum so if you're with
a guy and you're having to pay for him
if he can't offer you any protection
then really and truly what is what what
is the need for him there's no need for
you to have him there but that doesn't
mean that traditional men don't exist in
traditional world don't exist and if you
make money this thing where women now
make money that that was money should
never be a reason that you cannot still
have a man follow his leadership
um and now this thing when where yes you
can go out and earn and you could even
earn more than the man but that does not
mean that his role has diminished now
because Emmanuel was never just about
money and finance it shouldn't it
shouldn't but sometimes it does because
of the toxic masculinity and the the
toxic masculinity doesn't exist it
doesn't exist
forget that term then but I'm saying I
agree with you it shouldn't be that way
but unfortunately it is because of
insert whichever word you want
doesn't allow it I think it's it's
hypergamy women want to date across and
up I think it's natural to women
um but
I don't think money is the end-all
be-all nowadays but has anyone here been
in a traditional relationship that they
will class as traditional or in a
traditional relationship
traditional
um like it to the point
um I guess where the lady like Emily was
saying the lady is the nurturer at home
and the guy is the protective provider
goes out makes the money and the woman's
like a stay-at-home mom I had a taste
yeah I had a taste of it funnily enough
in college I had a taste and it was just
his security job and I was at dance
school but it was that really nice
coming home I'm doing the dinner he's
getting in the bath and you know what I
mean so I've had a taste but with men
with over the age
of 18 no
oh really why do you think that is
uh my choices first and foremost
um uh
I wish I knew I knew what happened to
the guy in college yeah why don't you
why'd you keep that one he's the one
that got away kind of because he kissed
a girl once in our early stages and I
left him
and I regret it because what I've been
through with my exes after him like he's
a good kiss that's nothing I'm like I
kicked myself I'll be honest with you
how old were you uh this was from 16 to
19. I use 16. yeah 16. do you ever think
like
women he did another girl advise you to
leave
like your friends okay no because I
always I hear a lot of times girls will
leave when they when he cheats but then
they don't find someone they love more
and so it's like you know it's it's like
is it is it better you know it's
a traditional relationship you've been
in one
China
um no because I'll be married then for
me a traditional relationship ends in
marriage okay so if it doesn't matter if
she plays the part for a year or two
years if it doesn't end in actual
marriage then it doesn't matter so it's
like I think sometimes people look back
in relationships and they'll be like oh
yeah oh my ex did this for me or my ex
did that for me but I'll be like if it
didn't end in marriage then what does it
matter what x did for you because they
didn't actually do the ultimate thing
that will show you their traditional man
or woman
um do you believe that relationships
today have to end a marriage yeah for
them to be successful well my thing is
this is is
is
if a man doesn't want to marry you then
he hasn't got good intention for you
long term that's what I believe you
don't think so when men women are paid
to leave the contract it's such a bad
contract nowadays where women are
incentivized to leave so like honestly I
think men have good reason not to want
to get married nowadays no I understand
that but if we if we talk about the
family home and we know about it we know
about all the statistics and and you
know being a two-parent home and having
a father that's in the home like like if
you really care about your family as a
man you would do certain things we also
know that there's certain certain
protections that be marriage does for
your wife as well and does for your
family so I just think ultimately
um if someone loves you that much
they're going to want to make the
ultimate sacrifice and commitment to you
commit with marriage yeah so let me live
with a with a 50 40 divorce rate where
she can leave take half and take your
kids you don't you don't think that some
men want traditional outcomes but
marriage just isn't on the table for
them I I believe marriage is on table
for everybody but it just someone it
depends what you're willing to risk and
a lot these men you had to put risk to
get in the place so to make it easier
though to make it easier right um I want
to like do like a little thought
experiment right so
you have a holiday destination
and it's your best holiday destination
it's the place that you've always wanted
to go and you can get it you can go
there all expenses paid
right
however
when you get on a plane you have a 50
chance of getting to the holiday
destination
are you gonna get on a plane
yeah plain analogy aren't good for me I
don't like planes anyway all right
because it doesn't give you the outcome
that makes sense to you right but are
you going to get on if it's 50 50 chance
to get to that your best destination
that you've always thought about and
you've always cared about and you've
always loved but you've got a 50 50
chance of getting in would you get on a
plane oh okay I'll give another one if
there was uh yeah you haven't answered
that one yeah bro no you know what it is
because you're using a plain analogy and
I just don't really like planes but if
if there's something that I really
wanted then it was 50 50 chance that I
was still gonna go and get it in this
type of man I am so the risk is worth it
so I would not that's disingenuous you
know damn no you would not no because no
because I'm not talking about the plane
because you're talking about uh you're
talking about losing my life money is
not losing yeah because the thing is no
but the thing is with marriage you can
marriage marriage can lead to a lot of
men commit a lot of men are committing
suicide after being you know taken to
the cleaners by women their children
being taken their house being taken
their cars being taken and it's one
thing when you're a young guy but when
you're you're 50 55 you're tired and she
can she can leave you and take all of
your money yeah to understand like
you don't come from that that's not your
what you've seen growing up that's not
what I've seen growing up yes I'm aware
it happens but if that's not what I've
seen growing up then why would I be
scared of it like for me for this thing
that you put this thing you're saying I
understand it because it's a different
generation of women right like we
remember like the women of that
generation were wives yeah but I I
understand that as well but I'm not
gonna say all the women are in this
generation are not wives like I think it
makes it quite easy to find the wives
when everyone is clearly not words right
so if you're if you meet a woman you can
tell the good women from not the women
that's why they don't they don't hang
around for a lot they get snapped up so
quickly because once you discover oh my
God she's a good one guys are literally
doing the most there's some goals like
like I said before another show that
they don't have to do anything men just
do everything you know why these aren't
the women that are arguing and beefing
you over this over the stupidest things
they literally good women and and
there's not enough of these women out
there so when we spot them we wipe them
and we lock them down
um and these are types of women that get
married but good women still go off
straight so women are real the dice and
this is we can say as women you know you
know ladies ladies we can all think of
one girl as an absolute hoer used to be
a hoe and she could hide it but yeah
like girls girls are a roll of the dice
and I think men think they're a lot
smarter than they are and that's that's
what I'm saying like why like I you
don't think that some guys wouldn't be
interested in marriage because of the
contract incentivizes women to make poor
decisions yeah no I like from a legal
perspective if I was a guy I wouldn't do
it I fully understand what people are
saying I fully understand what you're
saying I'm falling inside what you're
saying but at the same time that's
that's for me that's the union that's
yours yeah I'm not gonna have no baby
mother like that's not something I would
have like I would have a woman that's my
wife like to understand like like to me
okay cool to have a baby mother all it
takes for you to do is have sex with
someone and just and that's it and the
qatar's gonna be the thing is I don't
disagree with you yeah but what I'm
saying is that for me the reason why I'm
asking that is traditional relationships
dead is because we're living in a
different time okay and I think adapting
to the time may be what human beings
need to do and I think sometimes we're
trying to hang on to the old ways and
bring them into the new and we can
clearly see in this Society it's a new
time yeah but it's a really new time
yeah but in the west I was gonna say
look look I live in the west spot I was
growing up an African upbringing right
so there's there's no reason why for all
of us to lose our morals and lose our
heads it becomes very dangerous when you
get put into a society or place and all
of a sudden now you start getting new
new ideas on how relationships would be
this is why people just decide they can
be a giraffe today and everyone's gonna
say you can be a giraffe like I I like
like I am I'm quite aware of where I am
and what country I'm in and and this
even some of the things I've said you
get people saying oh my gosh you're so
all of the things they'll try to lay
before having it for a man having a
voice but I understand it so I'm not
gonna start to change my beliefs based
upon where I am no I'm going to be the
same person and I believe there's going
to be people because my my sisters were
raised as wives for other people's
sister for other people's husbands so
ultimately other people are raising
their their daughters um and their
sisters to be husbands um to be wise for
me so there's ah sorry I'm not saying
wives don't exist I'm not saying there's
no wives in 2022 I'm saying legally as a
man if I was a guy I would not want to
sign that contract
and I don't think it's like does he love
her enough does he not it's it's it's a
contract that you are paid to leave I
think you can still do a ceremony with a
ring in your church whatever but legally
why on Earth would you do that as a guy
like I I honestly if you really
understand the legality of it I honestly
think it's not smart I think it's dumb I
don't know if I was following what you
were saying right right because I don't
know if I heard like
contradiction right can I ask you would
you say that you're in a traditional
relationship right now with your sweet
one
um traditional well no I'm not married
so yeah I heard you say that but would
you forget marriage like a traditional
relationship well well she listens to me
um she respects what I say hi in my
chest
see the reason why that hurts your chest
is because you was with a man that
didn't do anything for you
my last man did a lot for me but that's
that's not why it hurt my chest no but
I'm saying like see when a woman listens
to you because she trusts you in
leadership she understands that this guy
I'm with um he's not going to do me he's
not going to steer me down the wrong
path um he's a he's a strong leader
that's why she listens to me so I'm not
she doesn't listen to me because she
hasn't got her mind of course you can do
whatever she wants I do not control any
woman but when you're with a right man
you were actually fall into your
feminine and let him lead and do certain
things because you trust in his
leadership and a lot of times when women
go my chest is because they haven't
experienced that oh it's because that's
what you led with but I've heard what
you've LED with your leadership no but
what I mean is what I'm trying to say is
see even the shocking it that's not what
girls do now you want to be with a guy
that you trust his leadership absolutely
I thought you would listen to No no
absolutely absolutely
yeah so why does it hurt your chest
because it was what he led with no
because what I'm saying listen that she
listens to me is that a problem no it's
not no I'm just trying to understand
like why what is it because to me that's
ideal
you don't think so it's ideal to have a
guy okay let me explain go ahead I want
to be able to listen to someone right I
have is I'm going to listen but perhaps
if what you were to say is
she can trust me or something like that
or she left see the problem but she lets
me lead her it was just the phrase and
the fact that that's what you led with
in terms of right but that's but that's
what submission is right if you believe
in submission that's trusting him even
when you don't want to yeah I think it's
for me it was the um choice of words and
the fact that it came with that was that
was the first that was what he left but
that's the thing about you know women
like men when men speak they just speak
women hear things like oh my God you
could have said it differently yeah but
we can't deny that there is there is
meaning behind people's choice of words
so so that's that's it's just it is what
it is what I get is it I'm really tired
of women always telling me how to speak
like do you know how do you know how
much control
you literally just did no I didn't you
literally just didn't tell you how to
speak I told you what what would have
been but I'm not telling you how to
speak you go you go ahead speaking of
course I want to speak how I want to
speak but you're already telling me the
way I'm speaking is a problem in it
because you couldn't you couldn't yeah
you're right so it comes down to you not
me I haven't said I haven't said
anything disrespectful I didn't say you
haven't I'm talking about how I'm
talking about so don't turn it into no
I'm not that's not me no no okay you
literally just said you had a problem I
know what I said but we're not going to
confuse what I said and make it okay
okay so let me just speak right this is
this is something that tends to happen
with a lot of women right men speak
direct I'm a very direct speaker I will
say what I need to say I said that um
she listens to me all of a sudden you
had negative connotation with the word
listen so she listened to me because she
trusted my leadership they shouldn't I
shouldn't have to I know I understand
the word listen yeah so you're just
misunderstanding clarified can I can I
can I finish because we'll just keep
doing this yeah thank you okay no I
haven't misquoted you you said something
so I need to follow up on what you said
because because what you're doing is
what women always do to us men so we
speak direct we're articulate we say
something then you want to say you
should say it in a way like this we are
not women see the problem is the types
of men that you are attracted to
ultimately speak in a way where or or
act in a way where you may not like
um but when I'm speaking I'm never
speaking in a derogatory way about women
I'm never disrespecting women I'm just
simply saying that if you trust in the
man's leadership and ultimate submission
is showing is is love and when and when
you love a man you're not going to
question certain things so if it shocks
you to say oh um
um she listens to me it just says to me
that ultimately the types of men that
you've dealt with haven't spoken like
this or when they have your pushback
yeah yeah definitely I definitely think
I'm a good listener and I crave someone
that I can listen to right like when we
were speaking about the one that you
know was you called a bum I love that
um I couldn't listen to him he couldn't
lead and I crave that because I want
someone that I can feel secure with and
be like yeah you've got so then why why
choose somebody who you can't do that
with because I don't see it at first I
don't understand it he didn't have a job
um no no no he had a job he's a creative
so he he owns if you meet him and walk
into his office you'll think wow this
guy's got it together but that's not the
case but then you were still supporting
him I was supporting him yeah so the job
was the job wasn't making money no
because it's like it's um
it's not a facade it's just you know
there's there's a job one month and
that's month nothing you might get a
massive sorry he's like a contract yeah
exactly how long did you support them
for uh six months and then and then you
cut it off you couldn't do it anymore
yeah that's not too long that's not that
bad yeah some girls come out and they
say like three years
there was a girl on here I was like I I
done a course on what is it um on music
because he was a rapper and I was gonna
be like this producer I'm like yeah you
like really invested in that bomb do you
know what I'm saying this ain't build a
bomb
I think that's a problem with now as
well because of course Instagrams are
like people's CVS and stuff and it's so
easy to portray yourself one way and
then when you go to their house yeah but
who do you think is more deceptive men
or women on Instagram I think both oh
come on I think women are specifically
and like lifestyle but guys with like
you know money girl you think I think 90
of guys have ass Instagrams like they
have like 500 followers with three
pictures most guys
though it's not even that you see men
like I I tend to find that a lot of men
they don't know how to take pictures so
you might look at their Instagram and be
like oh my god wow he's so not my type
you see him in person and it's a whole
different story I fall in love with
men's comments on Instagram like if I if
I see you think in a certain way and
like I don't even know what you look
like you could just be a Grace Circle
and I'd be like
now you wouldn't fall in love with mine
very much
so when it comes to traditional
relationships right
for the past year right I've thought
about this a new relationship contract
and I'm saying pearls held it already
and
um I've said it a few times
but I think
that men and women because of the times
we're living in should have rolling
contracts for relationships meaning the
two of you should sit down stipulate
what you want in a relationship and have
a rolling contract however long you guys
want it could be a year two years six
months whatever and then after that time
you get to renew it but within that
contract you guys both get to stipulate
exactly what you want out of the
relationship
what'd you guys think of that bad idea
okay why because how now I'm throwing up
contracts for my girl this is not this
is the worst idea ever you drop
contracts for for marriage yeah I know
but in listen and that doesn't work so
counting 50 50 50 50. so put if you're
drawing a contract in a relationship and
a boyfriend a girlfriend scenario it's
not that deep so basically everyone is
single until you're married like that
everyone's up for game the only way I
know that you not to approach you if
you've got a ring on your finger so when
someone says oh I've got a man
yeah but we're living in a time now
marriage doesn't matter people people
are having hold affairs with them with
them
the reason why I'm coming up with it is
because my thing is
there has to be a solution to the times
that we're living in okay and so we
can't keep trying to fit a square peg
into a round hole if it doesn't fit now
I know everybody keeps talking about
marriage marriage marriage marriage
marriage but when you look at the
statistics it's not working so I'm the
type of person who sees something sees
us not working and offers a different a
different perspective now it may not be
the right perspective but what everybody
can see is that this thing is not
working so if it isn't working
what's the new model so it's marriage
without marriage
this marriage without matter yeah it
could say that it's marriage so then we
should just do what we're doing already
now because end of the day there's no
way it's a little bit more now
well on the other side it Advocates more
for the man that's that's basically what
Sarah is saying but then I mean even
nowadays you have one in four marriages
that are sexless so men get married
thinking they're gonna have sex and they
don't even have sex and she puts on a
lot of weight after she gets the ring
and then you know she leaves you and
takes half yeah and then within the
contract you'd say you know you wouldn't
be able to gain a certain amount of
weight you wouldn't be able to know him
inside or not why not I will why not
you have to have a certain amount of sex
it's up to upped because a lot of like
Pearl was saying
a quarter of marriages are sexless so
why would I get into it into a
relationship knowing I'm not going to
get sex as a man because that's one of
the things that we love and it's
interesting because I understand like
what you're saying because you know I I
do in a way because I I do like I think
marriage like it was a good thing in my
life right like for my parents were
married most people I know were married
but the thing is like the more I learn
about the contracts I'm like I could I
could see a guy being very devoted to a
girl being with her for 10 plus years
and just no ring because it's a bad
contract to sign so you're willing to be
a baby mama then no no no no but I think
legally you know but that's what I'm
saying I don't need it legally but I I
think like not being having a part of
the government that's fine no but if you
can't if it's not you get married in
your church
okay okay cool like me personally okay
so if we get married in the village in
back home
um it's going to be similar to what
you're trying to say right but you're
still legally married to each other do
you understand what I'm trying to say to
you I think what we're trying to do now
is we're trying to create new
definitions for what marriage is
supposed to be and what relationship if
that's the case then just and then just
do what you'll do and you don't have to
actually I mean have a contract I think
they're just trying to find a solution
for a bad deal no right now the contract
is a bad deal for men so just be single
and just do your thing that's what a lot
of guys are doing yeah but that's cool
that's what I'm saying I'm saying so a
lot of guys are doing that but marriage
nowadays like If we're honest with
ourselves if we're actually honest with
the society in which we live in marriage
is a joke and when I say that it's a
joke do you know why because marriage is
a TV show Love is Blind 90 Day Fiance
Married at First Sight marriage has
become entertainment
it's not there's no sanctity in it
anymore so when the same women that are
sitting down to watch Married at First
Sight and love is blind and nighty Day
Fiance the same woman saying oh yeah I
want to get married you're literally
watching marriage as a TV show it's not
there's no sanctity to it anymore and so
that people can literally say okay I got
90 days to get a visa to to marry this
woman that's not marriage yeah but so I
don't think like yeah that's marriage is
a joke so so if we're gonna say marriage
is a joke based upon Night and Day
Fiance like nah man you need to stop
watching no it's based off of the
numbers it's based off of one in four
marriages are sexless one and four the
average length of a first marriage is
seven years and it gets smaller and
smaller based on how many marriages
there are it's based on the fact that
the men are paid if women are paid to
leave and take half and take your
children that's why it's a joke it's not
it's not based off of a TV show yeah so
I hear what you guys are saying I hear
what you're saying but
um no
seriously you think about it because it
doesn't feel nice to you that's the
thing it doesn't feel it doesn't feel
nice and I understand where you are
because I was there at one point too no
no I could listen I haven't gotten to my
age or not had any kids because I don't
because I can't come on like I've got in
here because I don't want to have a baby
mum's and I could easily have like my
friends have baby mums but I've seen
what it's done most of these kids that
are growing up doing the madness on the
on the road now they they're coming from
single parent homes
so even this thing over you're talking
about if it's not marriage it's not
going it's going to be the same thing
that we're seeing right now so when
we're trying to go out now and say you
know what actually let's not get married
let's write a contract why are you gonna
keep to the contract because because the
contract is more um it's more individual
whereas a marriage uh contract is more
broad like you said men when it comes to
marriage they get the short end of the
stick if the marriage breaks down like I
said I said 50 50 before you didn't like
the um the airplane allergy but that's
what it is like marriage goes to a train
what a train yeah yeah it's not a train
is it a plane is an automobile because
everything that you every knowledge that
you give towards America includes death
and I
a lot of guys commit suicide because
think about think about put yourself in
those guys shoes you work for 20 30
years you're still young you lost
everything tomorrow you could still
build it back yeah but right but I'm
saying this guy's 55. his wife leaves
him if he has children that are still
under the age of 18 she takes the kids
he and she is paid to take them and give
him less time and then he has to start
from scratch at 55.
yeah he took an l yeah good for women
though let's remember that women do have
like a hard time in in divorces
sometimes it's not I know I know
you know girl how
how you've built the man up to what he
has girl yeah I hate it when girls no no
why don't we take credit for men's
success if your guy was successful he
was going to do it with or without you
we didn't build anyone else we didn't
build anyone up my dad is a top one
percent earner I grew up around these
top one percent five percent man I
promise to God they love their wives
their wives are there for them but they
would have been rich with or without
those so if you built this man right
yeah if you're building this man
I'm just using it
so if you if you built this man yeah and
you're saying this man is only
successful because you built him yeah
and and and imagine that no I don't like
that that's not what all right but let's
just say that that let's just say that's
the Pavilion psychology of certain women
right why is it now if women feel that
they've invested into a man and built
him up why are they the ones that 80 of
the time that are filing for divorce
because if I if I if I invested in
something
if they're college educated
why leave it I can't talk because every
every relationship's different I don't
know what's going on in the particular
you know I mean in those num in those
statistics I don't know what happened so
I can't really I can't really do you
know what I mean but I know that yeah I
just wanted to just remember we're not
it's not just oh the man's depressed and
you know lost everything there's a lot
of women that end up in the gutter after
after divorce and men that leave their
wives as well not just women that up and
take everything well even even if they
do leave they're legally protected men
aren't so even even if a guy does you
know trade you for the younger model or
whatever yeah it needs to be changed I
agree on that yeah so would you say that
in today's society men are more
traditional or women are more
traditional men men
oh okay yeah at least they try to be
they want you know
why do you think that is so because no
music no a lot of the time it's it's
with
So within with all the new age feminism
and yeah some of the music some of the
cult some of the things popular culture
that they follow
um women don't feel as if in actual fact
it seems to be a negative connotation
attached to tradition being traditional
so even when I said she listens to me
all of a sudden that created a feeling
of something in the chest of until we
explained it but it still created
something submission it seems to be some
nasty word as soon as you say oh she
will submit women hate that word because
submission for them it means that they
can't leave the house they can't do
anything they can't have any friends
they can't wear it I'm not saying for
you I'm saying majority of women no I
just saw your face but I'm just just
just making it clear but women don't
like the word submission but for us men
we it's not a negative word you
understand it just means that you trust
on our leadership so so yeah yeah
I want more more men to be made of stuff
that we can trust your leadership
because I think a lot of men in this
Society are leading from a very weird
place and I get it like it's difficult
to say weird what do you mean like I
just feel like they're just they're just
so
[Music]
um
cautious and whatnot and they don't
trust that you know if they meet a good
woman and that she is just she does she
does mean well she doesn't have bad
intentions and whatnot they have this
like elephant in their brain kind of
thing that doesn't allow them to sorry
sorry
um
what was it that you asked me what did I
mean by yeah would that you said they're
weird men are like
weird no quote me what I said you said
they had this elephant in their brain
before that I said this weird oh I think
they don't trust good women
yeah like it's difficult for them to
to be to allow them in there's always
like this Barrett this kind of barrier
of distrust you wanna hear an
interesting stat yeah I'd love to
um did you know that
under 30 one in three men are sexless
they haven't or they're either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
men under 30 one in three or either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year where when where everybody in
general yeah did they ask you this is
statistics a lot of times like when
girls will say um like something like
those guys need to be like they don't
want to let us in like kind of kind of a
similar like it's the tough guy who
doesn't want to let a good woman in Blob
like you know I don't want to start not
just respect I've just done a lot of
these shows they're talking about the 20
of men that women want but most guys are
they're down they haven't had sex in a
year one out of three I mean like the no
they're they're down to commit I promise
to God if there's a guy if you've been a
Texas in a year and a girls wants to
come into you you're ready to wipe her
yeah because you want that feeling you
want to feel that feeling again so I
think that like be that being said some
guys will settle for less just to get
that feeling yeah yeah yeah like you've
got to remember like a lot of guys were
just settle for what they can get so it
seems sometimes for you women that are
pretty as well it's it's quite hard for
you to understand that men don't get sex
because you're thinking about the top 20
of guys that you're thinking about but
when you next time walk into a shop and
the Tesco's or you go into
um into Footlocker JD Sports whatever it
is just look at those guys that stacking
the shows look at those guys the guys
you never see those are these are the
guys that are not getting anything yeah
no no no because um these are the guys
are not that are not getting any any
attention so for me it it really just
comes down to a woman's choice because
it's just the guys you choose you're
missing all of the good all of the all
of the guys which are not on your radar
potentially could be guys that could
work for you but you keep looking at
these 20 of guys and these are the guys
if you looked in your friends if you
looked in your DMs it's not just you
it's everyone it's it's literally
everyone because if if you're single
right that means the guys that you want
don't want you otherwise you'd be with
someone I could be with someone every
day no you could be with someone but you
don't women yeah but the thing is you
don't want want them which that's the
point like anyone that's single it's the
guys you want don't want you anyone yeah
you know otherwise you'd be with someone
yeah
but what's wrong with all the guys that
what's wrong with the 80 of guys those
other guys what's wrong with them what
did you mean like the guys you don't see
what's wrong with them they don't I
don't know where they are no I love no
swag I love a lazy eye the buck
ET like if you see my type can I give me
a give me an example
can I see someone on Instagram you don't
have to we don't have to put them on the
screen I just want to see if I actually
I would like my ex yeah show me show me
one show me one we won't put them on the
screen or anything well I
what type of oh hey
we got a new face all right all right
bring your mic closer to you
hang on let me help you out
listen let me do it
let me show you
I had a whole fold up
well have you still got photos of your
ex because I made him a um photo album
of all of our time together for his for
Valentine's last year so to print out
all the photos I had to make a folder
I've probably did so you didn't delete
it I think I have because I can't find
it yeah oh no I didn't
wow wow what do you guys okay actually
question for the girls do you guys keep
pictures of your ex no I need to clear
out my hole okay so she does you can't
say no you can't I know I got a better
one no no I'm gonna ask you yes
oh wait she's muted I think
can you talk yeah yeah okay yeah that's
good yeah yeah I do do that but I've
started deleting them now though because
it's that little jump or the Fright that
you get when you see it it's not not fun
is it gonna keep pictures no I
definitely delete the pictures because
it's so toxic like why are you reminding
yourself yeah of the person that is no
longer in your life yeah I think it's
more Snapchat memories it's not like I
have an album with them like from
Valentine's Day
I do a scrub after I'm like I can't
because it's Snapchat memories that's
the problem that's it you might just
look at his picture one day and be like
oh my God I wonder who he's with right
now what he's doing I'll be honest Pearl
yeah as a man yeah when you get with a
girl
this and this is I'm going to put this
out to all the guys that are there when
you get with a girl you have to be ready
to understand that it's probably at
least five to ten maybe even more that
I've got pictures and videos of your
girl on their phone like like so if you
think about old yeah
we're getting the uh the evidence yeah
so if you think about all the girls that
send picture that girl he is not ugly
let me see let me see let me see no
because this is what girls do it's girls
no but that's because girls only find
five to twenty percent of men attractive
women women find 80 he's not I give him
like I give him five six that's what I
guess let's not oh your captain man your
captain your captain yeah yeah he gets
his man he gets girls he gets girls he
gets girls you don't think five six yeah
foreign
girls find 80 of men unattractive eighty
percent
interesting that's fine 55 roughly
percent of women attractive you don't
why would why is that interesting to you
you don't think that girl's like
guys that
other girls like you know girls like
guys or other girls like yeah they
because it's a competition
I don't know because I didn't I don't
think I'd go for the girls that the guys
that other girls like there's a certain
thing that I like about a man so so the
thing that you've sort of got like a
certain way some girls you don't think
most girls will if they know they can
keep him
like like if a girl could let's let's if
this is an extreme example but Drake how
many girls are lined up to date Drake
nobody's thinking oh he has too many
girls around her
yeah I guess yeah and but if girl and
most girls if they thought they could
keep him and retain him they would hook
up with Drake yeah for sure yeah but the
thing is like a lot of girls know you'll
be one of many
yeah
they're okay with that women that have a
man of that state of Drake status or
whatever status it is they don't mind
being one of many
because they because they know the deal
because they know that other girls like
him yeah but that yeah that's part of
his crop that's being an artist that
that's the kind of hat you have to put
on your audience or your fans will like
you but your one person is you so if you
so if we if we now bring it to the
quote-unquote real world it happens here
too so when women in the average woman
is looking at men she's looking for that
top 20 guy
that when we ask women what type of man
do you like what does he need to have
what does he need to have what does he
have to look like women tend to choose
men in the top 20 percent
so if if 80 of women or majority of
women are choosing that top 20 of men um
how many options can change isn't it
because what makes them the top 20 is uh
collection of things right and those
things can change those things are
attractive to women oh okay so so
they're attractive to women so those is
that why the race that's broken down
then because they're going for the 20
and then [__] check stuff because I I
don't know because I'm just saying if
those top 20 of men have 80 of women to
choose from so you girls are all going
with numbers you girls are all going for
20 of men so if if if if 100 of women
are going for 20 of men who has the
options here so you women yeah no I get
it exactly what you're saying but so you
could easily pick so the thing about
women is you you go you women are not
honest you don't pick the men that women
other women don't find attractive and
and you don't pick the men that other
women don't want so there's loads of men
when you think about how many guys are
out there you could easily pick one of
these guys and they would worship your
feet they would just be so happy yes
that's what I want no but you don't you
don't but you know
you don't no you don't you don't because
if you did right now you've been married
listen you'll be married just called off
an engagement right oh
Revelations yes that's what I'm saying
don't get confused like my the the nice
guy the sweet guy the guy that looks
after his mom the guy that doesn't have
a lot of money I want to love you
actually I have a question was it always
that way so you said you're the nice guy
the sweet guy has it always been that
way no the guy that I told you that you
kissed another girl he was like the cool
guy like super super tall like yeah got
all the swag when would you say that
switched where you were looking for when
did you start looking for the nice guy
uh well uh sorry that's difficult that
guy that I just explained he came about
because he saved me from a very bad guy
who was a fugly ugly oh a fugly so my
type has like always been like I I don't
know I'm attracted to like
uh the the not the not um uh typically
or stereotypically beautiful men he was
cute the one you just showed me so when
when you say you called off an
engagement
yeah so he was going to engage he was
going to propose one day like people let
it slip and then I kept on hinting like
I don't think it's the right time it's
not the right time it's not the right
time yeah okay and then he didn't like
the Ring's there the Ring's still
sitting in hand Gardens like after a
while like I just realized that it
wasn't gonna work so why because there's
just too much going on right yeah two
too much going on
was it was he a good guy
I wasn't a good guy
so then why would you accept the ring
then it doesn't make anything I didn't
accept I know but I'm saying I called it
off I know at the point of us going to
like look at rings I thought it would
work and then the realization kicked in
so I didn't allow myself yeah what what
you sound like to me is you sound like
you've dated Bad Boys you've been
attracted to the bad boys not not the
ones that would take you down the aisle
and at some point you realize actually I
need to change what I'm doing yeah
that's what I just said okay so so but
initially you're given so this is what
women do right you spend you spend your
20s to the point when you're in the 30s
chasing the wrong types of men then once
you get to your 30s you realize actually
I shouldn't be doing this right and you
you've been chasing off Chad and Tyrone
and then your options start to diminish
and at 30 you're like okay what the hell
have I done but in reality there would
be men or Pretty Woman there'd be men
that would have taken you up that would
have happily done this but you'd aired
them you literally did not see them and
the reason why you didn't I was loyal to
crap yeah no but so but the thing is the
whole story generalizer isn't it it's
what women know but it's like you're
telling me something I already know so
I'm trying I'm letting you land no but
she's agreeing so basically the reason
why I'm saying this is because I've
we've done we've done this show we speak
to women like if you use your 20s and
you end up in your 30s and you do not
have a man you've had from at least 17
18 you had about 12 years for you to
lock it down if you didn't it's not
because you didn't meet any good men
it's because you literally outweighed
your options and now you end up at 30
years old and now you're competing for
women in their 20s with the men that you
would want so then so then and this is
what happens with men in their 30s and
40s right
that is when they become more
established and that is when they become
a little bit more attractive
um you know most millionaires don't
become millionaires until they're like
30 late 30s early 40s sometimes 45 and
so the men that are that have watched
the women right they've watched women
curb them I don't want them eyes are
geek guys of this these are that I don't
like him they've watched that throughout
their 20s and then they've established
themselves and they're watching now the
same women who didn't give them any time
now like oh my God I I want those type
of guys in their lives
not me love yeah that's what they think
they're like not me because when it was
time when I was kind of showing you
exactly who I was and being a good guy
and I could be a good guy you wanted the
thugs on the street that would get your
door kicked in at four o'clock in the
morning